amlaykum
and how are you guys
doing? Um this is a very important
lecture about the preserved
Quran, the preservation protected book
and what I try what I'm going to try and
do inshallah in this webinar is I'm
going to try and go through all of the
controversies and all of the solutions
to the controversies. So what you should
be aware of now you should have um a
good kind of um
understanding of the main controversies
that relate to the Quran being preserved
and how to deal with those. Now
obviously from an Islamic perspective we
have
so chapter 15 verse9 that we have
certain certain yeah he certainly sent
down the book and we indeed we will be
his guardian. It's a theological uh
tenant of our belief to believe that the
Quran is preserved. Now obviously before
I continue since this will be quite
educational hopefully what I um request
from those who are listening as I
usually do if you follow my webinars is
if you're taking notes to make sure that
they're organized so that you can refer
back to them because we are going to be
putting a lot of heavy machinery on the
table. we are going to be going through
some things which I I think I suspect
many people listening to this will not
uh grasp in the first instance. So in
order to ease and facilitate the
educational process make sure that it's
not passive learning because a lot of
the stuff we are going to be covering is
not easy to to understand that. Uh so uh
we'll start with the basics though. I
mean so the first thing you're going to
be writing is what we're going to be
covering. You don't have to put all of
this down, but the first thing we're
going to be talking about are the key
areas of controversy. When I say
controversy, we're talking about
difference of opinion both within Islam
and outside of Islam. So, what Muslims
um are in controversy with with each
other and what non-Muslims will say in
order to
potentially say that the Quran is not
preserved. So, we have to know what kind
of controversy we're talking about. And
then we're going to talking we're going
to go in chronological order. So from
from the companions and then the mus at
the time of the codeex uh and some of
the objections and then we're going to
go into the discussion of what are the
and what are the some of the main
opinions.
We're going to be focusing on his view
and we're going to be thinking about the
view that has the greatest explanatory
scope and I'll add here the lowest
burden of proof as well. Uh, and that's
I mean when you're making an argument,
you always want to make an argument with
the lowest burden of proof and the
highest explanatory scope. That's
usually what you want to do. But it's
not only that because you're trying to
make an argument and win the argument.
It's that that which has the lowest
burden of proof and the highest
explanatory scope is usually that which
is the most sophisticated or most
correct answer to whatever it is we're
trying to find. So, we're going to be
talking after that about the primacy of
the oral tradition. And then we're going
to have questions. The last time I tried
to do this, I did have um a serious
migraine. I I suffer from and have
suffered from migraines for for years
now. Um something internal within the
brain and uh so I could go through this
properly. So this hopefully will give me
a chance to go through this with you.
Now this um this is the areas of
controversy. Okay. um
in terms of
so you've got 10AT we're going to talk
about what those are okay you got 10AT
which are 10 uh ways of accessing the
Quran there are 10 ways of accessing the
Quran and we access the Quran through
what you call the recitations yeah the
and theat are named after the main if
you like recitational masters.
Yeah. Who um taught their students.
Okay. So if you read Quran now, you're
likely to read in okay
is which means it's
a student of okay is this individual
okay who was the master ofat of his
time. There is 10 major masters, but
actually more than 10, but that we use
now in the Muslim world to access the
Quran. You see, when we're accessing the
Quran, we don't we don't just open the
book and try and read. We access it
through a normative recitation.
And so, there are 10 normative reciters.
Yes. the main masters of
and
this is what we consider the Quran. So
these this is the way in which we ask
the Quran. Now the question is first
question is there variation? This is a
very important question is there
variation when it comes to the 10? The
answer is yes. What kind second question
what kind of variation is there? Okay so
these are two very important questions.
Listen carefully. Yeah. Number one
question. Is there variation?
Answer. Yes.
Yes. We'll we'll answer how and we
account for this variation. But number
two, what kind of variation is there?
That's the second question. So the first
question was what is there variation? We
said yes. What kind of variation is
there? We're going to cover that. Okay.
Now within the 10 uh normative within
the seven there were seven and then
expand the Bible into 10 normative
readings. Yes, you have words which are
either or. So for example when we recite
Quran everyone who's listening to this
should know
so we say alhamdulillah
until the end of the surah within the 10
readings there are two ways of reading
the word
so the word melik here can either be
read as melik or it can be read as melik
you see these are two different ways of
reading this particular word okay so it
can be Melik which means the owner or
Melik which means the king. Now so
within 10 the 10 different readings yeah
the only difference that you're going to
find in terms of words inah fat is in
one word and that word is melik and
melik. Now the question is okay surah
fat is quite small surah. What if we ask
about the whole Quran? Listen carefully.
What about the whole Quran? What is the
how many differences and variations are
there in the entire Quran throughout the
seven major readings? Now IB Mujah was a
classical scholar scholar, one of the
most leading names obviously existed
about a thousand years ago and he wrote
a book called
and he says that there are 700 places
around 700 words which have variance.
Yes, 700 words. That's what he says. So
within those seven uh normative readings
there are 700 words. What kind of
readings are we talking about? What kind
of differences like melik which means
and melik? Do these differences have a
narrative altering implication? The
answer is no. It doesn't change the
stories of the Quran. It doesn't change
and I'll say this tenitatively the
second part the creed of Islam. There
are some of them which have an
implication on creed which I'll explain
to you which ones they are throughout
this uh this webinar but
they don't have a narrative changing
implication. We're talking about 700
words. Now in my correspondence with one
of the I'm not going to call him an
orientalist. He's actually an academic.
Okay his name is Van Putin and I had a
correspondence with him. is seen as
leading manuscript editor of the west.
Um and I actually told him this I said
you know 700 words uh and that can be
explained as we're going to come to
through the and so on and so forth and I
can actually read out to you what he
said. Now this is not Jay Smith or David
Wood who is an ultra preparian who has
no formal training on these. This is
someone who's at least got some sense of
the Islamic sciences non-Muslim.
This is what I said to him and I can
this is on my Twitter right? So I said
to him look
about this. I said
yeah I said uh but this would only apply
if the 700 words. So I was there was a
conversation here going on 700 words.
Yeah. which is called
which is in in means the where the
meanings change and means where the
pronunciations change and and we'll talk
about the difference. There's 700 odd
words in the
uh tables as around out of 77,000. Now
there's 77 I want to say this 77,000
words around in the Quran. Now what's
700 out of 77,000 less than 1%. Yeah. So
I said from
what you're saying so he was saying
something before is totally in line with
that traditional view
pay sorry pay attention to what I'm
saying what am I saying is that those
700 words bear in mind I'm saying this
to not what someone who's on my side no
I'm saying this to an orientalist it's
it's actually public record said look
the 700 words it's in line with sorry
the traditionalist view what did he say
he said I agree
I've seen that number 700 before and it
seems low. Did some back uh of the
envelope calculations and would think
it's about double that number. Okay,
let's go with it. Yeah, still only he
says still only a tiny percentage of the
words that is actually disagreed upon
though. So he agrees. But he says with
one caveat, let's say it's a,400. It's
about double. Now if you guys have
written essays, I'm sure many of you
people have written essays. you have
written essays or you have read blogs
and you have read vlog you know uh
articles and so on and so forth for
those individuals who have done that
what is 700 words in English what is 700
words what is it about an A4 paper and a
half like one and a half are we talking
about two A4 papers let's say 2,000
words like what uh Van Putin was saying
1,500 about two maybe 2 A4 two A4 yeah
maybe 3 A4 for okay five 6 7
what's what's the problem you're telling
me that in 23 years okay this is what
I'm saying in 23 years the and this is
the claim the traditional claim that the
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam when it came to select words he
couldn't say and for example
which means very similar things you
wouldn't translate it differently.
That's how bad. Check it. Or how would
you even translate that differently?
Very similar.
500, 600, 700 words. A,000 words, 2,000.
How long will it take you to read a
thousand words? How long? Take you 20
minutes, maybe less. Maybe 10 minutes,
honestly, if you read quite quick. So
you're telling me 10 minutes of speech
couldn't have been said over 23 years?
Basically the controversy and this is
the point here guys. The controversy
okay one of the main areas. So the
question is is there a controversy?
Answer is yes. One of the main areas of
controversy is to do with the variance.
Write this down. to do with the
variance.
Question one, are there variants? Answer
is yes.
Question two, what kind of variants?
We're talking about variants
which don't have a narrative altering
implication, but they are differences in
words, both of which we uphold as Quran
and as speech of Allah and so on.
So this is what we're talking about. Now
there's a secondary layer of controversy
and I so what did we say we said
throughout the canonical text the
normative readings that's one layer of
controversy are there differences and
variances the answer is yes now the
question a secondary question and this
is important very important
are there varants outside of the manic
script
in other words can do we find
manuscripts do we find manuscripts and
palmsts and different um you know
material which has completely different
continental structures and completely
different words before and after omitted
included
or you know from that which we have of
the manic text that's the second
question because theic texts the 10 can
be read through them but sometimes you
have manuscripts that are notic and that
have different kind of words in them,
word order
and the question is can they sometimes
be different?
I mean this is an important question.
This is a very important question. The
answer is yes. For someone to argue a
Muslim to argue that no all of the
manuscripts are the same, this is a
foolish argument with all due respect.
And by the way, not only is it a foolish
argument, it's not even an Islamic
argument or one that we need to defend.
And this shows you the weakness. And I
have to say, it's not our fault. It's
not the fault of the orientalists and
the disbelievers and the David Woods and
the J Smiths. It's not their fault. It's
our fault that we don't look into our
own tradition and realize what it's
actually saying. The question is number
two question, very important. Are there
differences outside of the manic text?
Answer is what am I saying? Yes, there
are. I'm not saying there isn't any
differences. So, there are differences
outside the Yes. And such differences
are even documented. Listen carefully.
They're even documented in the hadith.
There's hadiths of for example
saying I don't say
I say
is a hadith. So we recite inah chapter
but Abu D who was one of the companions
he doesn't recite he recites
how do you explain this how do you
explain the fact that the manuscripts
where it says
it says you know
and then it says in there how can you
explain that
how can you explain that this is the
question because if you're someone at in
the beginning of this that doesn't even
recognize the controversy
then you will not be able to recognize
the way in which our tradition Islam
itself solves these controversies. N
yes.
So the two questions that we started
with are there variance? Yes. What do we
say? What does the tradition say about
the variance? The tradition says that
the prophet recited it like this and the
prophet recited it like that. He recited
Malik. He recited Malik. How many contra
how many uh words are there different?
Ib Mujah says 700. Van Putin who's meant
to be expert no Muslim expert says no
it's about double no problem double
triple quadruple 10 times no problem
even 7,000
has it got a narrative altering
implication no so far we're following
are there differences
yes are there differences outside of
theatic text is yes how many are there
so this is actually quite Good. Because
brother Nazhan, I was reading this. He's
got actually probably one of the best
things I've seen in the English
language.
It's actually on Y. Yes, there's
controversy here on Y and but this
article is good. I I can vouch for this
article. It's one of the best in on the
whole website and you can see on the
bottom and he shows
he he shows quoting someone else
Muhammad
who says that now outside the manuscript
how many variants are there with the
narration?
He he says 19. So you got 700 from Mujah
and you have 19 outside the script. This
is nonsense. this how I mean this is
minor 19 words 19 differences
this is not a monster now we're going to
come to how the or not the orientalist
because by the way most orientalists
won't do this it's the evangelists yes
the evangelicals and the evangelists and
those individuals they make it out to be
a monster the orientalists they're
they're not the what you think they are
I mean some of them non-Muslims they're
not like what you think I swear it's
just when you have conversations they'll
agree with a lot of what you have to the
traditional narrative they will agree
with it and you know it's not as as as
stark and dark as many people make it
out it's not like that so what kind of
difference is 700 according to mujah and
19 outside of the manuscripts how do you
account for those differences outside
the manuscript now we're going to talk
about that today but that's an important
question which you're not going to get
an answer to right now you're going to
get an answer to maybe in five or 10
minutes time so you have to listen Pay
pay attention to this. Right?
But before we talk about that which is
the meat before we talk about that which
is the meat, let's talk about the the
basic history. Okay. Okay. So we believe
as Muslims that the prophet wasallam he
got the
divine revelation from Jirel
and then he transmitted it during
prayers during this during that many
different things and he would
continually so the prophet wasallam it
wouldn't be the case that he would just
recite one surah at one time he would
recite it many times in prayers inaw in
this context in that context in many
different contexts you see but he
uh he would recite these things. The
prophet asked the companions to recite
in front of him. Now, how do we know
that? Because as we're going to come to
the prophet Muhammad, the the companions
use very important word.
Yeah. Is that the prophet taught us this
way. Yes. Can't say that they were
making it up themselves. The Sahabah
were not making up themselves. The
Sahabah were not making up themselves or
using whatever words they want. If that
was the case, why are you using the word
which means that they were that the
angel sorry that the prophetam he was
teaching me sorry this is what the word
means this is what the word means so
once again this there's a claim out
there that the the companions would put
in whatever word they want no they
wouldn't sorry they wouldn't do that and
there's no evidence of this in fact and
there was no or allowance of that I
don't agree with this because if that
was the case how come the prophet Mam
the companions
in the famous hadith Hashem
and Hashem himself and obey and many
many many of the companions would use
the word
that the prophet taught us this way.
Yes, he taught us exactly like that.
Moreover, that the companions when they
used to be in prayer with one another
and some of them made mistakes, other
ones would correct them. If you could
just read it willy-nilly wherever way
you wanted to, there would not be no
correction. Sorry, there would be no
correction. There' be no for there'd be
no way to do doesn't make sense. Doesn't
make sense. Sorry, it doesn't make
sense.
So here it's very clear
that the prophetam he taught it to the
companions and the companions they
taught it to each other. Now why is it
that some companions they read it in one
way and then they did of the other way?
Meaning what? meaning that they said it
wasn't like this and there are
narrations like that. say you know I
it's like I just mentioned to you
the difference between the two it is
because of the and that's very important
that we're going to go through this but
the tell us and this very important that
the Quran was always a multi-
formal text was a multiformal was not a
fixed text and these key words by the
way guys you should have a glossery and
you should be writing those key words in
the back of your glossy inshallah
because they're going to come in handy
when you have conversations to
individuals that are questioning the
preservation of the Quran. And believe
me, by the end of this webinar, I
promise you one thing, all of the major
contentions about the Quran and the
preservation of Quran, they will be
resolved. They will be resolved. And it
might sound like a brave statement or a
confident statement.
Yes. But I tell you something. So long
as what I bring forward to you is a from
the tradition and b has the explanatory
scope then kalas with due respect nobody
can come to us and tell us about the
preservation.
No one can come to us and talk to us
about that. So yes we talked about he
urged the Muslims to make it a central
part of their life. It was a it was part
of the culture. It was part of the
culture. It wasn't just something that
yeah and it was locked up in books or
this or no no no this was recited
recited in prayers. How many times we
pray how many times we pray a day
superogatory prayers additional prayers
voluntary prayers
where the Quran talks about people
praying for twothirds of the night. What
were they praying with for twothirds of
the night? One small surah. I doubt that
that was the case for the majority of
Sahab.
Yes, some people might have repeated the
same thing, but not if you're going to
spend twothirds of the night or oneird
of the night or one half the night
praying, what are you going to be
praying with? Clearly, this a staple
part. You weren't writing it down. For
the most part, these people were
memorizing, which we're going to talk
about.
And of course there are many different
things in the Quran and in the Sunnah
which encouraged the practice of
memorization which was something the
Arabs were doing anyways memorizing
things poetries and so on.
We have certainly made the Quran easy
for reminder and remembrance meaning as
well for who is going to be the one who
doesn't and the many hadith that says
that the more you know Quran
you're going to be you know being uh
read and ascend these are
uh encouragements to the Muslims of that
particular community to memorize the
Quran.
So clearly
it wasn't just the case though that they
memorized. They also wrote it down.
They also wrote it down. And we know
that there's many a hadith on that. I
don't even need to mention them to you.
And the Arabic context
as I've just mentioned is a context
where the Arabs were just memorizing
everything. They were memorizing
everything. Memorizing this. It's not a
iPad generation
phones and this it wasn't like that.
Okay. So the Arabs,
okay, were known for the their poetry
that they they would do. And by the way,
this is even mentioned in the Quran like
the the fact that the Arabs were like
that in in chapter 26 of the Quran.
uh you know that do you not see that
these poets are in every valley
praising and so on and so forth
and they do what they don't they they
say what they don't do and this and
that. So there these these these poets
are everywhere. They're commonplace and
people are listening to them. There's
their entertainment and they would
instead of videoing it or recording it
as we do today, they would memorize what
they say and go back to their families
and they'd all talk about what they
have. That's how that's how they
recorded information. This is what you
have to understand in that time. Now we
record how you record by putting on your
camera on your smartphone. But back in
the days they recorded by putting on
their internal camera their brains and
they would they would memorize the
information in the hearts of these poets
and they'd come back and u and and speak
to their families about. So this is
something which is part of the thick
description if you want to call it that
of that particular culture.
Now this this question of who memorized
the Quran there is a hadith that says
for but it's not just for and we know
from the plethora of a hadith that
people have memorized the Quran
and the were killed and so and so forth.
So it wasn't just four individuals that
just memorized the Quran. This is a
waste of time interrogation and even if
there were four as as the orientalist
if there's only four there that these
are the four that according to this view
which is not correct yes the four that
memorized the whole thing according to
this view which is not correct but then
it wouldn't discount the fact that there
are people that knew chunks of it and
they could put it together there were
thousands of Sahabah there were
thousands of Sahabah
so you see these are some of the names
of people who have memorized the Quran
it's not just the four that people say
that they think there is.
So of course going just in terms of the
basics here a year after prophetam
order be collected and he put it after
the battle of yama and this basically
this battle a lot of the people had
memorized the Quran as we've said many
of them had died which means that there
were more than four right and assigned
who was one of the people memorized the
Quran to accomplish this this mission so
they came together and they and they put
the musaf together the continental
skeleton and so on and so forth and they
gave it to
who gave it to who put it underneath
Hass's bed and it was there. So we had a
a musaf which is a book of an entire
Quran only a year one year after the
prophetam's death but of course at his
time there were parchments and other
things which shows you that the even
though the Arabs had such a good memory
and at that time and they memorized it
it wasn't just through the memorization
of the people it was also written down
so theic codeex
So we're going to talk about the a
little bit later and how could how could
it be one of the questions I started
this this webinar with that you can have
something which is outside the codeex
how can you have something different to
the codeex okay but before we talk about
that how did this is an important
question did the codeex form in the
first place so the codeex formed through
a legend a committee which was put
together at the time of a laf nan and uh
it had in it people like Zad who was
there obviously at the time of Abuaka
Sudik and other names that you can see
down there but there were this was a a a
committee of the most proficient people
of Quran people that had met the prophet
heard it from the prophet directly from
him and then they wrote it down into
different codices question have any of
those codices survived
answer no what you find now with the top
cap and manuscript and the pal and and
this and that. None of this is what
we're talking about when we say it's the
five or six or seven that had actually
written with his hand and so on and so
forth. This is a poor way of arguing.
What did you say? I said this is a poor
way of arguing. We never made the claim
in the first place that such mah a
survived or b need to survive. And those
people who do make that claim from the
Muslim side, that's a poor claim because
historical details will show us that
some of the most early
uh manuscripts that we have, they're not
actually right from the time of Ahmed
and they're first century. They're very
very early, extremely early. Like the
top cap manuscript is 99% of all folios
and it's in line with what we know. Yes,
but it's not at the time. Aman didn't
write that with his hand. Do we require
that a man wrote the thing with his
hands in order for the Quran to be
preserved? No. When we're talking about
preservation, we are not talking very
clearly about manuscript preservation.
Let me be very clear here. When we are
talking about the preservation of the
Quran, let me be very clear. We are not
talking about manuscript preservation.
We are talking about the preservation of
a spoken recitation from
from chapter 1 to 114 of the Quran. And
before someone comes in and says wellb
he didn't believe in was part of the
Quran but he was there at the time of
how comes he didn't object to the fact
that that was put into the codeex and
not only is that the case but how comes
all of the and the chains of narration
they go back to
And
so he changed his mind. Yes, there is
narration where first didn't believe
part of the Quran but clearly after that
as he mentions he changed his mind. He
was confused in the beginning and then
then he changed his mind
which shows you that no one is perfect
but that people came together and all of
the companions came together and they
said this is Quran
and this was then transmitted to the
next generations and so on and so forth.
So we can safely assume that the
manuscripts that we have some of them
would be a copy of those copies you see
of the manic codeex not actually the
codex in itself that's not what we're
arguing be very clear we're not arguing
that preservation of Quran or uh is
means preservation of manuscripts we are
talking and I'll tell you what we mean
by preservation but I'm very important
yes
Next.
So what they did was they they they had
the Quran they said okay this is what
what comes first what comes second what
comes third at that time there was no
dots
or thritical marks.
Yeah there wasn't any of those things
there. So there was the skeleton the
consonental skeleton it was there but it
could facilitate sometimes more than one
word which is very important. So the
continental skeleton can and that's a
key word you might want to put into your
glossery. It can facilitate more than
one words. Okay. Why would it need to?
We'll talk about that in what follows.
All other copies were burnt and this was
just to try and ensure that there was
one standard copy and others were not
allowed. So there was no confusion.
There was no confusion.
So clearly there's no doubt because if
all of these people are coming together
and agreeing all Sahab are agreeing this
is what we heard
and we don't see of any Yes. Listen, we
know that there were there was fighting
before this happened.
Yeah. Or
was said, go and go and sort out your um
before they become like Jews and
Christians who differed in their book.
So quickly sort it out because this
one's reciting in this way and this
one's reciting that way. But when the
the grandmaster Sahaba of the Quran came
together and all agreed this is the
Quran there was no doubt afterwards we
don't hear of any narrations of Sahaba
fighting each other thereafter fighting
each other say you don't read like that
and you don't read like that the job has
been done after this time we do find
narrations and this is what we're going
to come to the extra manuscript evidence
and extra narration evidence why is
there if it's true that the Quran is
only
allowed and so on and so forth. How come
you find things outside and Sahabah are
even reading with their H afterwards?
That's different story. We're going to
come to it. We're going to come to that.
Yeah. So, this is the the oldest mus
that I think we have. It's uh I'm not an
you know an expert on manuscripts quite
frankly and Islamicawareness.org
has got some really interesting uh
pictures and details of manuscripts.
This is the one the top copy one the 99%
folios and it's from the first century
it's not armanic but it's probably a
copy of uh of armanic script as you can
see here uh it's it's the continental
skeleton is exactly what we have now but
this is for us it's additional it's not
something which is just an additional
thing we don't use it as if there was no
manuscript on the earth if this one
didn't exist the Quran would still be
preserved okay and I want you to
understand that put that in your Fine.
All right. So some objections now some
say well there are there some verses
which were lost
and so for example in Ahmed it mentioned
relates relates that when prophetam
suffered the agony of death he got busy
and looking for him a pet animal came in
and ate the paper that contains some of
the verses and some of 10
you know but it's to say that herself is
the only person who knows the Quran a
very weird interrogation If you think
about it, but we have to remember that
there were some verses in the Quran
which were abrogated.
Chapter 2 verse 106. Some verses used to
be part of the Quran and Allah he
removed this and she herself believed in
that abrogation of those verses and
there are hadith and narrations to the
to that point.
So it's important to realize that there
are some verses that were parts and then
they were removed from the Quran. Yes.
And Allah mentions this in Quran.
He mentions this in Quran. So abrogation
is an important part. When did
when was all the abrogation finished?
When before the prophetam died, angel
Gabriel came to him and he read the
Quran to him twice and so on. And so
that last rendition was that which
remained the last rendition. There were
some verses because we believe in
abrogation which were part of the then
removed
chapter 2 vers 12 uh 106. Therefore this
is explained within the apparatus.
Yes the apparatus the mechanisms of the
Quranic structure already. So if someone
comes and says well some verse is lost
or this and that say listen this verse
was abrogated this particular narration
and herself believe in the abrogation.
So that's one one important to one
common objection. So we talked about
this already objection to
they say well he didn't believe there's
a narration that says he doesn't believe
part of the Quran. We say yes, he didn't
at first, but he clearly changed his
mind because his narrations of the Quran
include
we have narrations with his name in it
which includes how do you explain this?
How do you explain this?
It's narrated
and he was alive at the time of the
legend of Aman didn't take these two
suras out. Therefore, maybe in the
beginning he thought, you know, this is
not part of the Quran. It's just Tua and
then after he realized, yes, actually
part of the Quran. So, the fact that
he's in the chains of narration destroys
and eliminates
all of the uh claims of the individuals
that say, look, you know,
look at this, you didn't believe it was
part of he brings you a bkari or
something like that. Say yes, but he
changed his mind.
So now let's get to the juice of it.
Let's get to the juice of it. What are
the what are the before we get to what
exactly are the number one and you
should be taking your notes here. You
should be taking your notes here and
being very careful here. Yes. Saying
what this is what you're going to write
on top of the page. What are the you're
going to underline it with two lines.
You're going to underline it with two
lines
and then you're going to write down the
textual basis of so let's read this
hadith together
reported that I heard from Hashem and
sorry I heard and reciting
in a way that was different from how I
recited it and how I was taugh how it
was taught to me by the messenger of
Allah
peace and blessings be upon him this is
the word that we talked about he he he
taught it it wasn't just something he
heard or he can put whatever words he
wants into into it. No, no, no.
Yeah. I was about to argue with him. I
was about to take him. Really? But then
I waited until he finished and I tied
his shirt around his neck cuz was no
joke.
See, if this was if you can read the
Quran wherever you want, what are you
talking about? Why is doing that thing?
Why is he taking his shirt and wrapping
it around his neck? I mean, are you
being serious? You can read it wherever
you want. How come he's taking the shirt
and my neck and moving him and and took
him to the prophet. See how delicate
they were and precise they were. It
wasn't that he was reciting a different
surah altogether. It's just some
differences. And he said, "Wait a
minute. Why is he reciting it like this?
Is this guy trying to mislead me? Is
this guy trying to take is he trying to
change the Quran?" That's how he was
thinking. So he said, "You know what?
I'm going to wait for him to finish."
And then he grabbed him and he he he put
him in a in a hold.
Maybe some kind of choke hold. Allah he
tied his shirt around his neck. Sounds
like some kind of collar chokeold to me.
Maybe he I don't know. Subhan Allah was
a big man. He's a strong man. I don't
know how he did this, you know. He
wasn't he wasn't just playing around.
He said I said indeed I heard this man
recite in a way that was different from
the what you taught me. He went to the
prophet. He's in front of the prophet
now. He's asking him. He said look it's
different. The prophet said to me bring
him to me said bring him. Then the
prophet said to him recite
then he recited and the prophet said
listen
it was revealed like that actually. And
then he said you recite and then he
recited it and then he said it was
recited like that as well. Yes it's like
that and it's like that. So wait a
minute. How could it be like that and
like that? And then the prophet gave the
answer. Wait a minute. He said, "As it
has been revealed, verily, the Quran has
been revealed in seven dialects. Recite
whatever of them which you find easy."
Wait a minute.
Wait a minute. So the Quran, there's
some verses, there's some words that can
be recited in one way and that can be
recited in another way. Is that
something which the traditionalists, the
Muslims, the scholars had to invent in
order to try and explain the variance,
the readings of the variants? No, this
is something which has textual evidence
from the time of the prophet himself. He
said it
and this is probably one of the most
explicit a hadith that show us that the
Quran and put this in right this one
part to say now in your own words in
your own words that the Quran is not a
fixed text. Full stop. Point one Quran
is not a fixed text. It is a multiformal
text. Meaning we don't claim that the
Quran should not have variance. Listen
carefully please. Some people they're
still making videos for 5 years, 10
years. Are they foolish?
Foolish. We are saying we don't claim
that the Quran should not have variance.
We are claiming that they should have
variance. In fact, if the Quran only was
only one way, this would disprove this
hadith. Subhan Allah. Say that one more
time, please. Yes. If the Quran is only
one reading and there's no Malik and
Malik and
this and that, this would disprove this.
Say, what this? What is it talking
about? Why on earth is it talking about?
So, there has to be variance. And this
hadith, there has to be variance.
And the variance look at this was
to facilitate ease. Was to facilitate
what ease because there's some people
they find it easy to use one word and
other people they find it easy to use
another.
So, and if you look at all of the
hadith, and I haven't got time to do
this in this webinar that deal with
where the prophet is literally making
dua to Jirel to Allah through Jirel,
I mean asking for Jirel to send it. Yes.
The Quran to reveal it in a way that can
help the old people and the one who does
not know
how to read or write.
He's trying to make it accessible.
He wants it to be accessible for
everybody. This is the reason why
there's some words like this and this
word like that. That's why.
Now that's the textual basis for it. So
let's move on to the next one. So the
question is what are they? Okay, what
are the
the you see there's two major opinions.
Some say well there's 40 opinions.
Actually these 40 opinions they're not
they're not really opinions. You know me
mentions that there's 40 opinions people
don't take that seriously and with due
respect the the
specialists of the area they don't take
that seriously. Yes, there's not 40
opinions. There are there's 40 some some
of the things that people say are from
Sufi or something like that and say this
is not these are not part of the 40. No,
they don't have backing. And this is why
I'm saying this. I'm not saying this
Muhammad hijab. No, I'm saying that
these 40 opinions, they don't have that
much backing. The opin the two opinions
which have the most backing
are the opinions of the Quran and the
opinion one and the opinion of who is
the opinion of the
which is opinion two. Okay. So you have
two different kinds of opinion.
So let's go through each one. The Quran
people like
and others they are just saying that the
are seven categories of difference for
example word order uh words having more
or less letters etc. So what they're
looking at is that they they've got the
the tarat in front of them and they're
saying what are the difference what are
the categories of difference and
variation that we find and they
categorize seven such categories and it
must be said that someone like for
example has a different categorization
who has a different they all believe
it's
there are seven compartments if you like
categories if you like of difference
let me give Give you an example.
Let me give you an example.
Say you go to a car showroom
and you see cars in front of you. Yes.
You see different cars. Yeah. And you
see there's, you know, big car, a Jeep
looking car, you know, like a coupe. Uh
I don't know. I'm not into cars that
much. I have to be honest. I don't know
about the different kind of cars. Yeah.
Maybe you see a motorcycle as well.
Yeah. Maybe a skateboard there as well.
Yeah.
You see maybe a scooter maybe.
So you see different vehicles, a lorry
and they're different colors. Different
one. Black one, white one, red one,
yellow one, green one, blue one.
Now I'm within my right to say, look,
I'm going to put all the vehicles
together which are blue. I'm going to
put all the vehicles together which are
blue. And I'm going to put all the
vehicles together which are red. And I'm
going to put all the vehicles together
which are green. And I'm going to put
all the, you know, and so on and so
forth. That's one category of
difference. What? Color. Color. And then
I might say, look, I'm going to try and
compartment mentalize in a different
way. Now I'm going to put all the
scooters together. I'm going to put all
the cars together. I'm going to put all
the doors together and so on and so
forth. So what I have a different
category of difference. And then I say,
"Look, I'm going to put
uh, you know, I'm going to put all the
diesel cars together and I'm going to
put all the unled petrol cars together
and I'm going to put all the vehicles
with no electric cars and so on and so
forth. It's another category of change."
So what these people are saying is that
we're looking at different categories of
change within the sevenat or the the 10v
the most they call them the most
authoritative from mass transmissional
perspective from their angle and we're
going to look at different categories of
change and these are they would argue
yes these are the seven the different
categories would say it's like for
example I'll give you just one or two
and there's only one example of that by
Toba by the way but so where you have
one word
I can't remember exactly the
the the evidence for that but that's one
that's one category and then you have
another one then you have a third
category which is for example you have
uh you know
for example having pluralizing and
singularizing the same word and so on
and so these are seven categories you
So let's say these are the seven that
the prophetam is talking about these are
the seven that but there's a problem
with this view
it doesn't explain the hadith mentioned
previously that like you know how will
this facilitate and it's very difficult
to imagine yes you can you can argue you
can argue it can facilitate possibly
making it easier for the people but
making something a plural or a singular
is not really going to make it easier
for the tribes you know you could argue
this and I would agree with that is Is
that a hole in the narrative? Yeah,
maybe it is. Actually, maybe it is a
hole in the narrative. Did you say,
"Wait a minute. Some some some
disbeliever going to take your words out
of context." No, it's the hole in what
narrative? In the Quran narrative,
though that opinion, not in the whole of
Islam narrative. Come on, please don't
be ridiculous. Yeah, don't be
embarrassing.
So it doesn't explain more of it doesn't
explain
uh the the shad narrations or or
narrations which are outside of the
scope of
uh the the rest because the question is
now you've got these seven but are these
seven are not enough to tell us the
differences out manuscript differences
listen manuscript differences outside of
the manic
In addition to narrational differences
as well outside of really this is not it
doesn't have the scope to deal with
that. Let's be honest, it can deal with
the different the variations within but
outside it doesn't deal with it as good.
It has to be honest because how how
could it explain?
It's not really where does it fit into
seven categories. Doesn't really fit in
neatly into his categories to be honest.
Neither does it fit into seven
categories or seven which are all
different by the way. they have
different uh categories even though they
all say they're different categories. So
for example, going back to our analogy
of the the showroom with all the
different vehicles. So I can choose
color, I can choose, you know, petrol or
diesel, I can choose this, this that.
But all these people who say this
categor category difference, they choose
different categories. You see? So if if
the categories were so clear, someone
would argue, right? And rightfully so.
Why don't you all agree upon the same
categories? Do you see the point here?
So there are some issues. It's not
perfectly explaining
of all of the variables.
So that is an issue but it does have the
advantage of explaining at least okay
these are the categories of difference
and it does it doesn't go completely out
of line with making it easier for
people. I can imagine that how could
that make it easier but not in a in a
full way to be honest because the the
the word is before or after I'm not
really seeing how that will help a
person who's an omi like a you know you
got to think about that now's view which
is the view of the majority and of the
and of
not
says is the view of the majority of
people they say
he says and he expands upon this in what
in his work
because he had a work that was written
which was bigger which is now not in
it's not extinct been miscataloged or
something it's not with us today but in
his
he says basically this he says that in
one word you can have up to seven um
differences you can have up to seven
differences for example the word
means come here in Arabic you put this
Before we put this down, you're going to
write down what two major opinions the
opinion of the
when we said what is that opinion? Seven
categories of difference and each of
those individuals
and they have different cate category
descriptions. So that's opinion one
major opinion. Opinion two now is the
opinion of the majority of
they say that in one single word you can
have up to seven variations. So they say
for example the word you can have
and in the words you can.
So you can have different words up to
seven which
which these words which are up to seven
facilitate ease. And by the way this
makes more sense in terms of
facilitation of you have to say and I'm
not doing we're leaving this out there.
They both have their but if you think
about facilitation of ease I mean the
fact that you can say oral or clearly
that will make sense that okay this
makes it easier for like one Arab saying
we even say now in the Arab world you
know most Arabs say
I mean if I say to my mom
or my son or whatever he's going to say
what do you mean by if I say he don't
understand what I'm trying to say so I
can see I can see How using different
words which are synonymous. Yes, using
different words which are synonymous but
which mean the same thing but for a
different Arab tribe would facilitate
ease for different people and would make
the Quran acceptable to such people. I
can see that. But now there's a
question. Let me see if it's in the next
slide. One second.
The question is
how can we explain the fact
that like you do have these other
categories of difference. I mean we said
before that of the 10 theat only comes
one time. It's only one example but you
do have some other category of
difference. For example, you can have
the same word with the same what you
call in Arabic
has the same the same but it's not a
synonym but it has a difference. Now
this is all if if you don't understand
what I'm going to say I'm going to break
it down. I'm going to break it. Don't
worry. Don't worry. For example
in you have a verse in Quran where it
says
you have become aranged or you found
this thing weird and they make fun of
it. That's what the uh the ayah means.
And then you have another which says
if Allah is saying with a with a on the
means he is finding it weird. Allah
himself is finding it weird which is why
we said there this is a different thing
now this is a credle thing does Allah
find things weird does Allah find things
where how can you say now obviously
these two it's the same words but the
because in Arabic you have something
called which is not in English you don't
have in English and is
basically the end of each word
and so on and so forth and that changes
the meaning whether you're talking
and is it first person, second person or
third person the word is the same listen
the word is the same but now because the
difference you have in one and one has
changed the tense yes the the the the
opinion they do have that as well they
have a category of difference where it's
either first second or third person they
do have that however ever's
opinion here the problem with it is does
it account for such words which have
differences which are not synonymous for
the tribes now this is a very complex
question the answer is yes and how do we
know this we know this because if you
look at of that particular ayah he says
that both and this is something from
response he's the one who he sent me of
that oh he is to be credited for this
example and if you don't know response
channel you should know by now you
should be subscribed to his channel
actually how dare you not be subscribed
to his channel anyway so it's a very
good point that
he accepts the differences which are not
just synonyms meaning what meaning that
any category of difference which is less
severe than the category of synonymous
change can be explained to
through the whether it's within one or
within the seven either way explains it
that
sent it to prophet Muhammad in this way
and in that way and that's exactly what
he says in of that particular verse now
so here what we have's
opinion is a little bit more
facilitation and it explains more within
the tradition it explains more within
H the the tradition
in the sense that now we know okay it
facilitates ease. Yeah it facilitates
ease because you're using a different
word synonymous word. Another thing with
is opinion which is very very important
and now you should be putting it down is
opinion. Number one different synonyms
of diff of the same word that
facilitates for the tribes. It's not um
it's not limited to these differences.
Yes. So other differences are also could
be explained but because we don't have
the full extent work of the we can't
explain to you exactly he believes one
is this two is this three is this four
is that and so on it doesn't go like
that with him he doesn't do this he
doesn't go like that the Quran do that
yeah and the do that doesn't go into
such depth because really and truly he's
kind of it's almost as if I'm not saying
he's saying this but it's almost as if
he's saying I can't go into this
sequence
cuz I don't know exactly which are the
but all of the basically this is what
he's saying and this is what we need to
know one line one line all of the
variational difference
within the
are explained through the
whether you believe that the are exactly
seven because seven could mean according
to many of the scholars just many in the
Arabic language or you believe it's
actually there
that the are the explanatory mechanism
that we use to assess the different
variations of Quran
and what's interesting about is that he
says in his he says that
question
he doesn't believe by the way his
opinion in terms of is different to the
opinion of the Quran but
Many.
Yes.
Is it encompassing of all of the He says
no. Wait a minute. Why is that
important? I'll tell you why.
Because the that we have in front of us,
the Quran believed that all of the seven
are in them. Nobody does not believe
that.
One more time the jar and so on the
first opinion as you can see up in the
slide
etc. Those guys believe that that all
of the seven are in the that we have
whereas does not believe in that. He
says you can have a listen carefully.
You can have a outside of the mus.
What does this mean? It means that if we
find a manuscript or if we find the
narration or if we find something which
has a different lexical formulation than
the one we have in many must have one
conceivable understanding according to
and many of them is that it's a
but it's a that has not met the
conditions and we're going to go through
the conditions that are required in
order to make it Quran But it could be.
So the the question is if someone says
this narration of saying
how comes he was telling this man to say
then he says at the end or the one
talked about or this narration or that
we say it could be what's the problem on
top of his view is that you can have a
outside of the manic.
Now this is why is this significant
question why is this significant?
Because but pay attention. If you
believe that there can be a H outside of
the Musaf, every single manuscript
evidence which contradicts the mus is
irrelevant and is explained through the
according to not me according to
how.
Listen carefully. If you find any
manuscript in the world that goes
against
or if you find a narration within the
hadith tradition which does which goes
against
according to he says that's fine because
you can have a outside of you can
how does he come to this conclusion he
says the reason why this is the case is
because actually if The um it's the
preservation of Quran.
When you're when you're preserving the
Quran, do you need to preserve all seven
or do you need to preserve one? Very
important question because this question
is about burden of proof.
The do all seven need to be preserved or
does only one need to be preserved? And
by the way, this is a very important
question because when we say as Muslims
especially defending Islam that the the
Quran needs to be preserved or the Quran
is preserved.
Someone could argue is the Quran or
question is the Quran preserved with all
seven or is it preserved with less than
seven? Now pay attention because the and
the Quran they have different answers to
this question and so what we do is we go
with the we go with the less and I'll
tell you why the Quran will say no
actually in order for the Quran to be
preserved then all seven have to be
preserved all the seven have to be
preserved
and the says no actually only one needs
to be preserved. Why? Why? He says
because look when the prophet Muhammad
wasallam was telling us to read with the
did he tell us to read with the as an
obligation or did he tell us to read
with the as a facilitation
and he says actually he does so as a
facilitation meaning what you can choose
to read yes with this H or that H or
that H. So in order for the Quran to be
preserved according to only one needs to
be preserved meaning what meaning the
the burden of proof is lowered already
according to in the burden of proof in
terms of what is preservation is
lowered. So that's why I say in order
for the defense the intellectual defense
of Islam to be defeated we shouldn't go
with the we should go with the we should
go with the lower meaning what that only
one needs to be preserved
but we know that more than one half is
preserved because we know the variance
exist but according to even if the
variance did not exist
yes even if the if the variance did not
exist then
uh it wouldn't it would be immaterial
because we only need one. He gives the
example if I if I have an oath in the
Quran it says if I have an oath and in
this oath I go against the oath like I
swear incorrectly that something is
going to happen I have a choice of or of
clothing the poor or of um you know of
um fasting or of
so he says
this is a it's a license you you have a
choice if I do one of those things then
that's it. If I do then he says the same
thing by the way one of the major
scholars. If I just do one of those
things then it's
meaning
yeah so it's not I don't I'm not obliged
to do all three of those things. He says
likewise the ummah is not obliged to
preserve all seven it's only obliged to
preserve one and anything additional to
that
is it's good but it's not required so
that's an important point to summarize
this important topic there are two major
opinions
the opinion of the Quran is there are
seven categories of difference we gave
the example the show the cars and so on
the opinion of
is actually that it's one word up to
seven differences
synonymous differences with different
skeals but
it's completely different it's skeleton
and it could also include things which
are smaller than that which we talked
about
does he think that's all within one or
within the seven he hasn't spelled that
out because we haven't got all his works
however we do know that he does believe
it's all from Allah. Yeah. And that it's
all
says that Allah he sent down this Quran
to Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
like word for word. That's what it means
word for word. So that's what the two
opinions are.
So,
now if you if you heard some of the
apologetics and some of the weird
sayings of the anti-Muslims, they'll
say, "Look, there's a thousand
differences, 10,000 differences, 40,000
differences, and in meanings between the
lash of the 10." I've even actually seen
some
uh orientals,
this kind of argumentation in lectures
like
and he's like these are 10 masters and
look at this. He's trying to make a
monster out of it. My friend, there are
700 words. Let's say a,000 for a let's
say a thousand words differences. Those
7,000 words can take different
formulations.
So different arrangements of 700 words
can be in the millions. Think about
this. Say for example if I have 10 words
and of the 10
yes you can what I'm trying to say to
you is this of the 700 words the Quran
the 700 words differences they chose
different formulations of them so
clearly the different formulations if
you multiply them it has a multiplier
effect but it's only 700 words
difference and as I said before it has
no narrative altering implication so
we're talking about 700 words arranged
in different ways so what
does the Quran. Yes. Are 10 individuals.
There are 10 individuals who choose they
choose. Is it going to be Malik Med or
is it going to be Malik Med? Is it going
to be the owner of the day of judgment
or is it going to be the king of the day
of judgment? So when they come to that
choice, is it going to be king or owner?
That's called
this this
is called that's what they call it
they choose either
and if they choose with 700 different
instances then
if this choice is what creates so for
example when we say the owner of the day
of judgment that's because
and by the way because has the
they decide that it's going to be.
So
who is the teacher of when he taught he
taught him
when he taught
he might have taught him both but
was a he said you know what I'm going to
choose
now the chooses is it going to be or yes
it's going to be
it doesn't mean that because there's a
choice that there's
that that now the is putting his own
words in. This is nonsense. There's a
pool of pre-existing words that are
available and then the chooses which one
of those and all of them have the
backing the angelic backing of and they
all have the the
so in order to be authentic it has to be
three criteria. Please put this down. In
order for to be authentic, let's see if
it's in the next. Sorry, want to see.
Yeah. In order for the to be authentic,
it has to be in line with the
triangulated method. Number one, it has
to be with it has to have an authentic
narration.
A authentic narration. Number two, it
has to be what? And by the way, says it
has to be popular as well.
So number one it has to be authentic
narration. Number two it has to be in
line with the why because the
script is that which has the most
backing of the Sahab. So we know now the
script itself is not going to facilitate
all of the
according to view yet in order for it to
be
it has to be in line with number three
has to be in line with language.
This is what we call the harmonizing
method. The now chooses what word he's
going to put. Is it going to be melik or
melik? But the choice is limited to that
which the prophet said. Listen
carefully. 700 words that the prophet
said in different ways. He chooses.
He chooses those. There is a choice that
is made by the
chose me not
chose Melik not Malik.
So those choices are limited and they
are backed by the prophet they are not
but but arrangements of those if you
multiply them obviously they're going to
be in the thousands. If you multiply
them, it's going to be in the thousands.
But we're not the original is 700 words.
And if you and if you if you multiply
700 by two, three, four, it's going to
be in the thousands. But we're not
talking about thousands of differences.
We're talking about 700 words that have
different
ways of being recited.
That's it. So the gets to choose. Is it
going to be or is it going to be the get
to choose?
is going to choose
you know and so on and so forth
which is very interesting you know this
verse in the
you know means stars more than one star
and means one star so in one we have
many stars and that's what we know in
the cosmos interesting but yeah so they
get to choose Which is it going to be?
Is it going to be one word or another
word? But this that choice is limited by
the and by the it's important. It's
important.
Yes, it's important that textual
criticism from the Islamic perspect
some some fools say there's no such
thing as textual criticism in Islam.
There is there is and by the way there's
there's a harmonizing method. The
harmonizing method is what? the
triangulated method of the salad. Number
one, the narration, the chain of
narration. Number two, the the rasim,
the continental skeleton. And number
three, what?
Number three, what? You should be Come
on, you should be you should be paying
attention. Number three, what we said?
And we said the continental, sorry, the
the the
got to be Arabic language. It has to be
in line with the Arabic of that day, not
the Egyptian one or the Iraqi one or
this or that the No, no, no. It's got to
be that the the of the day, the
classical Arabic of that time, the
seventh century, which we have preserved
through dictionaries and through
poetries and so on and so forth. So you
see everything has a chain and the
reason why these became the most famous
is because they had the most students
and because their
has the most robust and authentic chain
of narration back to the prophet
wasallam. That's the reason why they
became the most famous. That's the
reason why they became the most famous.
You see? But you might be a bit confused
thinking oh I'm I'm I'm not getting the
difference between the and the
difference between the and the is the
following
the listen carefully so put this
question what's the difference therefore
between and the the are the differences
or the types of differences
yeah the differences and the variation
the is a choice listen all the choices
listen carefully
the choices
of said master of recitation
to incorporate one difference
from another
you see so that's what
is
so that's the difference between the and
the now you might not get this but it's
heavy material I told you already and
you that's why you have to keep
referring to your notes and go back to
this recording that you're listening to
now. You'll get it eventually. It's not
something you're meant to get. All don't
think, "Oh, I don't understand this and
this confusing." It's confusing. You you
should know. But this is what it's all
about. You have to go back and listen
again. I'm afraid. And a lot of
non-Muslims are listening. I've never
heard this before. I know the answer. I
know David. Bloody hell. What the hell,
man? What did I get myself into? Why am
I even talking about this matter? Am I
talking about this, man? I have not read
these books. I have I have no access to
them. J, what's his name? J Davis,
whatever his name is, J. Smith or
whatever his name is,
you know, he's thinking, "What the hell
is this? All these words and all these
terms, you know." Oh, brother, you
shouldn't get yourself involved in all
your respect. You know, these enemies of
Islam, you know, and this and that,
listening to this, thinking it's too
much more than I thought. They have
answers, actually. Oh, damn. I know
they're thinking that. I know they're
they're eating their hand.
I know that
now
the opinion of the has the following
effect. We can explain with the opinion
of
number one
that manuscript differences may be
because of the
possibly
any difference to the any manuscript you
give me in the world that's different
from what I'm reading in my salah and
what I believe is Quran I will tell you
it's conceivable that that could be a
end of discussion Don't waste my time.
It's it hold
what what
anything you give me, I'm going to say
it's possible it's possible that it was
abrogated. You get me a narration. It's
possible it was a it was possible it was
abrogated. These two things it's
possible that it was a it's possible
that it was abrogated. How can you have
a outside the text? Well, because
according to we don't need to preserve
all seven of the we only need to
preserve one. It's not just the said the
same thing.
Many of the say the same thing. Many of
say the same thing. It's the majority
according to that's the majority opinion
of Islam. Majority opinion. So get me
any manuscript difference any in the
whole wide world.
Get me any one of them please and tell
me here's something that's different.
Make a thousand videos, a million, a
billion videos. Make write a thousand
books and articles, peer-reviewed ones.
I'll read them and laugh because you
know why? I'll tell you because it could
be a and this is what I told Van Putin
and he agreed with me on Twitter. He
said, you know, you're right. It could
be explained. He's a non-Muslim.
He's a non-Muslim. I don't understand
how non-Muslims can agree with this and
some Muslims can have doubts about it. I
don't get it. I don't get how the fact
that some Muslim non-Muslims, you're not
even a Muslim. You don't believe in
light
and I'm telling you that okay, there's
some manuscript here and manuscript
there. Yeah, it could be a according to
and then yeah, yeah, it makes sense.
That's an inroad. It's true. It's
intellectually satisfying. But then you
have Muslims say I have got doubts. I
don't know. And this come be quiet. Have
some guts. Be a man. Stop being the
slave of the orientalist.
Come on. This inferiority complex.
Why you man? This is embarrassment.
Some some some people have been calling
me and giving me some uh uh uh uh
emails. Brother, I have doubts. What
doubts, man? What embarrassment is that?
Why you have doubts? Why
the orientist you've read, if you read
their work, should you be you'd be
surprised they're more on our side than
they're against us. You'd be surprised.
You'd be surprised. And some come out
and say these orientist and they don't
know what the orientist say. Some of
them are actually with us not against.
So tell me now you find any manuscript
in the whole wide world in the whole
wide world. Or you find me a thinking
narration which goes against the Quran.
What does it do for me? Nothing. If the
possibly it was abrogated possibly
What? What's the problem? I don't
understand. Why you have doubts? What
kind of man are you anyway?
What kind of woman are you? What kind of
Muslim are you? What kind of Muslim are
you? Let's be honest about the situation
putting doubts in that one's heart and
that one's mind and this one's soul. Be
quiet man. This is all in our tradition.
We have we we have a chain of narration.
Yes, we have a chain of narration that
goes back to the prophets and yes, we
believe the Quran is a multififormal
text, not a fixed text.
So yes, we believe in the variance. We
believe in the variance
and we believe that they're all from
Allah and we have the textual evidence
for that and we believe in the and we
believe in the
and we have a textual criticism and
that's that
and that's that.
So this has a great explanatory this
opinion of I would agree has a great
explanatory scope and It allows us to ex
to explain all of the differences within
the Quran that we have and we read the
Quran with and all of the differences
that may emerge outside from a
manuscript perspective or from a
narrational perspective. Tell me now,
tell me now how an orientalist has any
argument against the Quran, the
preservation of Quran.
Tell me how. Sorry, I just got a bit
passionate there.
But make sure you're taking your notes
and I'm sure there's a lot of things
that you got from that.
So why do you assume the manuscripts and
narrations that lie outside of the
Quran?
Why don't you assume that they're a they
may be a they may not be but they don't
have an authentic narration and if they
do they don't fulfill the condition the
triangulated
condition it's not just by the way also
has this conditions that have to have a
salah that's correct and other has that
condition has that condition has that
condition yes
we know we've read the books Sorry.
Orient says, "You have not read
anything."
David, would you have not read a damn
thing? All you're reading is what all
you get your information from is me. I'm
your teacher, boy. And all of you
people, I'm your teacher.
Your teachers
and you know it. Don't pretend to be our
teacher. You have nothing on us. You
have no nothing. Don't ever don't ever
come and step up to us for life. All of
you.
And I know you're listening to me. I'm
shaking. You need to use the toilet now.
I know you do.
Anyway, all of the major opinions need
to show that one health is preserved.
Only one.
The fact that we have and this is a very
good
I like I like there. I like the this
thing. Yes. Sometimes they have some
weird statements in some of this. Yeah,
it's true. But this one is a good very
good uh paper written by Nazir Khan.
Excellent one.
Read it. It's a fantastic paper.
We'll go to the next one.
So we don't need a manuscript. This is
the beauty of it all. The Quran is the
the word Quran itself means transmission
orally. So we don't need a single
manuscript. We don't need a single
manuscript to preserve the pres. We
don't need a single one. Not even one.
All we need is a chain of narration. Now
listen, listen carefully. Listen
carefully. And I want you to all listen.
I know the enemies of Islam are
listening to me. Let me take my glasses
off. Let me take my If you saw what I
look like now, believe me, a lot of the
enemies of Islam would be would be very
scared. Just like Apus was very scared.
Many of them would be very scared
because you know when we come to the
truth and the h
When we come with the truth and the h
and the and and all of the details like
this kalas, what are what you going to
do? What you going to do?
Question the preservation after this. Go
on because you know what? I went to uni
on a post-graduate level and I sat and
you know I tell you something. Yeah. I
sat on a textual criticism class for the
Bible and I'll be honest with you. Yeah.
Old testament. It's called text
criticism. That was the name of the the
module. And I was sitting down
and listen to me. They were talking
about the Old Testament. This was Old
Testament text criticism.
And the guy obviously they all knew
their languages like most of them. They
were kind of weak on them. They're not
not nothing like how the Muslim
community is with Arabic. They they're
kind of weak like Annie, barely can read
the Greek and barely can read the
Hebrew.
And
I asked the professor in the class, I'm
not I'm not an expert in biblical
textual criticism. And I had to ask
said, "What is the what is the
harmonizing method?"
Listen carefully. I asked him, I asked
him, "What's the harmonizing method with
the Bible? How do you know what goes in
the Bible and what comes out of the
Bible?"
Listen carefully
and write this down. Comparative
religion. Write it down. Underline it.
Harmonizing method. Underline it. Now,
the question is, what is the harmonizing
method for the Quran? me and you know
now it's the triangulated method you
have to have an authentic narration you
have to have and you have to have what
the Arabic language yes all three of
these things if it fits those criteria
or if it's according to it's Quran
now as for the Bible question
what is the I have a question what is
the harmonizing method for the Bible
Do they have a chain of narration? I
asked the guy, "Professor, big time, big
shock." No, it's no joke. This guy said
to him, "Do they have a harmonizing
method?"
Do they have a chain of narration?
Do they have to go in line with the
language? Does it this or does it that?
Do you know what he said to me? And I
will never forget what he said to me.
He said the Bible, the Old Testament,
listen carefully to all those people out
there that Christians, how dare talk
about preservation. It actually makes me
angry. Listen to what he said, not a
stupid running around the street
speaker's corner and talking nonsense.
This is a professor at the high levels
and this is all over your books. He said
the following. He said there is no
harmonizing method.
Wait a minute. What did he say? He said
there is no harmonizing method.
So, how do you know what goes in the
Bible and what comes out the Bible?
How do you know what goes in the Bible
and what goes out the Bible?
That's that's really it. And it goes to
the judgment. Really, you might as well
flip a coin. I think Bruce Meer
mentioned this in his book somewhere.
You might as well flip a coin. Flip a
coin to know what goes in and what goes
and doesn't go in. Sorry. You have no
narration. Zero narration. No chain back
to Jesus or Moses.
No chain. Don't speak to me. Don't speak
about Islam. Don't ever open your mouth
about Islam again. Don't open your
mouth. Don't ever open your mouth. You
have no chain. Going back to either
Moses or Jesus. You have no chain of
narration and you know it. And a lot of
you are losing faith and you shouldn't.
I know the Christians are on this chat.
Lose faith. I tell you, lose faith. It's
better for you.
Because this is a nonsense. You have no
chain of narration, no chain. And in
fact, the Old Testament, he told me in
front of me, he said, "Look, we have the
Maserati text, you have the Dead Sea
Scrolls, you have you have the you have
the Maserati text, you have the Dead Sea
Scrolls,
and you have the Septuagent." And the
Septuagent is not even in Hebrew, my
friend. And they say we translate it
from the Greek into the Hebrew and then
put it into the text. It's like it's not
even the same language. It's not even
the same language as that which Moses
spoke. It's a translation.
And you're making that one of the
primary sources in your text criticism.
And you're comparing with all audacity
because of the ignorance of the Muslim
community and the weakness of the
leaders. You are comparing your method
of preservation with us.
You have deceived and selfd deluded.
Donn Krueger affect you jokers, you
imbeciles. How dare we talk about the
Quran? You imbecilic individuals.
It's not even in the same language
and they put it in there. Let alone
and this and that and were going to beat
each other up because they didn't know.
Is this one saying it? Get the hell out
of here. Get the hell out of here. And
these Muslim weak Muslims in the in the
West sending me emails and this I'm
losing my face and I'm a half. I'm get
the hell out. You are never a strong
believer in the first place. You
weakling. You're a weakling because you
don't know your tradition. You're
sitting there watching Netflix and you
don't read the books of Islam. That's
why you are where you are. That's why
you are where you are. You basil. It's
our fault.
There's no harmonizing method.
And so today, inshallah, we should have
covered we should have covered
the chronology, the history. We should
have covered what is the what is the and
of course the primacy of the oral
tradition. With that, I leave it for
questions.
Actually, I shouldn't be saying I should
be saying yes. I'll be leaving it for
questions now. So, I'm going to be
reading some of the questions
right now. Okay.
Someone was saying okay.
Yep. Another person. Why was the 99% of
the Quran in the early manuscript? It's
obvious the 1% was added in. It wasn't
added in. They have 99% folios and they
don't have 1% of them.
Why did she say that there were holes in
the standard narrative? He made the
mistake by saying that. He shouldn't
have said this. He was talking to me as
if he should like were in a in in a in a
classroom talking about the Qurat's
views. He told me that he believes in
view. He told me that he believes in
view. He doesn't believe in the Quran
view. We said there's two major views.
And he was talking about the holes in
the Qurat's view.
And you're talking about the holes in
Iban Jazzi's views and so on which I
agree there are holes in that view. So
clearly the the disbelievers they're
looking for any words a formulation of
words to destroy Islam. Subhan Allah.
He says
whoever wants to follow someone let him
follow that who the people who died the
same person we just mentioned one of the
m of Quran for the one who's living the
fna has not alleviated from him or from
her meaning why is everyone so hung up
what happens about sorry if he jumps off
a cliff we're going to jump off cliff if
commits suicide we're going to commit
suicide if he did this we're going to do
with him and if they have to become
apostate we're going to become apostates
and you what is your what's wrong with
you for someone to really I find it yeah
amusing and battling how individuals in
the west are so attached to person what
happens if I become disbeliever
what happens if I change my mind become
shia you're going to become shia if I
become shia you're going to become shia
if I become a you're going to become ahi
if I go you're weak
some of these individuals they're really
hung up and I'm it's not it's our fault
it's our fault that we become celebrity
obsessed individuals
I didn't get into da so that people can
hang on to my every word and to this and
that and it's embarrassing and it's
humiliating
there's some sahaba there's some people
he was sahhabi had became a disbeliever
sahhabi the the disbelievers also become
the sahaba also become this sahaba there
were big scholars that became
disbelievers ex-Muslims and apostates.
Does that mean when those become
ex-Muslims and apostates that we're
going to religious switching is a part
of human life? I'm not saying yes and is
going to fit into that. But what I'm
saying is why is why are people so hung
up and with all due respect about what
people think he saw what what said
there's holes in the standard narrative.
That's all I'm going to say. That's what
he said. But he said I he believe the
Quran is 100% preserved. That's what he
said from what I remember. He said I
believe the Quran is 100% preserved. So
yeah, I mean why don't you just hang on
to and leave the but if it comes out
with anything other than that then we're
gonna we'll deal with that. But that's
I'm sorry that's all he said publicly.
That's all he said publicly. If you
bring something else what he said in his
emails and this that's not my business
what he said in his emails and what he
meant is deontextualized. I'm sorry I
can't comment on that but that's that
you stop being like obsessed celebrity
obsessed personalities. Would you
respect? Who cares what why he cares so
much? Why? Why doesn't matter what he
said to be honest with all your respect?
Does this work?
We'll be given notes. I don't know. Can
you tell your
opinion
says he believes in opinion of that's
what he says? What I just mentioned
today is what he believes in. He says he
believes in that. Now whether he's true
to that or not is something that if he
publishes anything in the f future, we
can look at academically. But that's
what he says. He says there's there's
host in the narrative of the Quran is my
understanding of of
so that's my understanding
how many authentic narrations of the
Quran are there including
well look there's that's that's a very
complicated question I don't understand
what it means because there's you got
the then you have so at what level are
we talking about are we talking about
the level of we talking about the level
of talking about
the question is I don't know and that's
the question that is the golden question
to be honest how many are there and
that's why there's difference of opinion
and there were many books that were
written at the at the time of the
about this question about how many
himself had a which which went because
he his his whole book his compendium was
lost so the question is difficult to
answer with all due respect it's
difficult to answer I can't give you an
answer
uh Yeah.
Did Did early use
I don't know. I don't know where you're
getting that from. I have to ask the
someone from the the because I'm not I
don't know about that question if if the
use is but the question is it's wider
than that. Some people would read like
in kufa and this and place with
is true like and this and they used to
read with certain that were attributed
to so they at the level of before the
came to play they wouldn't obviously
they wouldn't be saying I read with
because
these guys weren't around yet so they
weren't teachers yet so they would be
reading at the level of or the names of
they would say for example
They would this is the har of this
person or that person. So what the early
is used is b I have to go and do
research for that. I don't know.
Yeah. Someone's mentioning the
Birmingham manuscript.
Oh, sorry. When would the
added
um so yeah. So
appointed
to put them in. That's that's the
standard opinion. That's that's what it
is. But obviously there was other kind
of when we talk about dots, we have to
be careful because there were there's
all kinds of material now that's just on
dots. Are we talking about the dots that
are we talking about the dots that make
the difference between and so on and so
these dots? Are we talking about the red
dots that tell us the the one that that
that demarcate one from the next and so
on and so forth? These are all different
questions. But if we're talking about
the ones that make the
then and the
Yeah. So this was quite early on. Uh but
different dots have different times and
this is different. This is if going into
manuscript analysis is different. But
yeah, the reason why the dots were not
there in the first place, what you call
is so that the or the consonental
skeleton of that that that word, the
lexical phrase would would um facilitate
more than one reading because as we
said, it's multiformal. So there are
some words like melik and melik.
Nowadays if you look at the if you open
up it's something called so this you got
meal is spelled
but then you have an alif which is like
a dagger dagger al if in the middle
which is symbolic of that facilitation.
So it's one lexical phrase which has the
ability to um to indicate both reading
which is a beautiful amazing it's so
amazing how they made this how how how
the wall they're genius they're geniuses
and when you put the together he
actually had this by the way it's not
when we say it's not just one it's more
than one some say seven one to one to
one to Medina one to Mecca and so on and
so forth one to one to this They sent it
and when he sent it he sent it with
people to read it out which is very very
important because you know when we let
me give you one example how when we say
the word London how do we read the word
London if you go to Cambridge learners
dictionary it'll tell you there's a it's
called awah these kind of learner
symbols it's completely different but
how do we why do we not use the word or
read the word London it's lone don
the reason why we don't read it
phonetically as it's spelled like the
graphim doesn't associate particularly
finely with the um sound is because and
the reason why that's the case is
because um
um is because someone's taught it to us
like that. It's simply human people,
individuals have taught London to us.
That's how it sounds which shows us it's
not just oh this is an ancient way of
dealing with language. No, this is the
contemporary way of dealing with
language and this is the only way of
dealing with language. Why do you read
it Polish and not Polish and Polish and
not Polish? homographs and homonyms and
all of these. Why do they operate in
that manner? Because of context and
human communication. So
to indicate his seriousness when it came
to the presentation of Quran, he sent
the but he also sent a person to read
with the mus. It's like in if you want
to put it in modern Poland taking
someone giving them a book and then
giving them like a you know a cassette
or a video or or a video to listen to
how it sounds as well. This is the
highest level of presence. Tell me one
other ancient document of that time that
has that kind of level of it. Tell me
one. I want to know. Give me a name.
What the septuagen the maserated text?
Are you joking?
The Septuagen which is a translation.
Please man, please like the Christians.
It actually makes me physically angry.
Physically angry that they're comparing
their method of preservation with our
makes me physically angry. How dare you?
How dare? And then when they're calling,
they say, you know, we're just being
honest. Yeah, we have text criticism.
You don't have we do have
and we have
and we have a harmonizing method. The
only difference between us and you is
you don't have a harmonizing method.
Anyway, sorry.
Obam believed that there were 160 years
in the Quran did he change his mind?
Once again,
all of those individuals whomever said
there was anything more or less than the
cannon either they changed their mind or
they didn't believe in that in the first
place
or they didn't believe in that in the
first place. And those two additional uh
dua that were readab was reading he
didn't believe was part of the Quran
that was the dua of you you read it when
you're you doing and stuff why would you
think that he thinks that that's part of
the Quran and if he did he had to have
changed his mind because his also have
only 114 suras he had to have changed
his mind he can't all of his companions
all of his compatriots are reciting it
one way and he's going Oh no, that's
sorry. This is not even about this is
about so it's there's no there's no mal
there for change for for that. The
prophet said that there are seven. No,
he said there seven.
He didn't say that there were seven. He
said
he didn't say
he said
don't confuse theat and they they are
two different things they're separate
things theat are different from the
yes theat incorporate the the do not
incorporate theat that's how it is theat
are the different the difference in
theat are the the differences in theat
wherever they may be are the that's what
it is even if we take a view even if we
take a view the differences in the Qurat
are the now
my question is how can
both belong to the same tribe and have
different dialects because both of these
are high listen this is a very I I don't
accept this interrogation some of this
is mentioned in the classical books and
they say well is and is how could they
be reading in different ways? But there
were not any sorry
was
the top
uh people in the in the whole community.
Do you not think the prophetam is going
to teach and and
a a dialect which is outside of his
tribe? Is he was not one of the ignorant
ones. He can take Yeah. He can take
learning Yeah.
which is not from his dialect. What's
the problem? He doesn't require is what
I'm saying. There are some people that
require ease and he was not he didn't
fit the category. If you look at the
hadith that says that people that
require were the weak ones, the old
ones, the little sorry not the little
ones the the old ones the weak ones the
the
one who couldn't read.
So didn't feature for him. It didn't
require he didn't require. So why would
the prophet make it easy for him and he
doesn't look it's like you're giving him
it's like asking this going to a
bodybuilder and saying how comes you you
you gave him 80 kgs to do bench press
because he can he can handle it he can
handle 80 100 120
so why does he require the facilitation
just because they're from the same tribe
doesn't mean this so clearly that's not
I don't know it's just not the best time
is the best book on that you recommend
in English. I don't know about books to
be honest in English. I haven't read too
many of them. But in Arabic there's
of
And these two will give you a good
grounding because we've just covered
that today. So if you read those two
then you'll be okay. In terms of the
English language, go to that. This is
actually one of the best things I've
read in Japan.
It's actually one of the best things in
English. I've read that much in English.
It's 40 pages and it will give you an
overview of some of the main opinions.
40 pages. It's very good. So, go to
that.
Something that confuses me. If all
follow the code, how comes there are
added letters and words in the narration
of such as such as
[Music]
and so on. Yeah, I get you. Because when
we say the text is that there's more
than one.
So,
He had one with
and he had another with you see. So when
we say theatic text we're talking about
all of the which sometimes you can have
even in the even
but usually it will be like in you know
and other so and without min and well
and without well and so on which as I
say it doesn't really make a difference
to the narrative but yeah because when
we say
we're talking about the the the the the
that which endorsed and once again we
don't require it's because now it's
preserved through the so theic script is
reserve is preserved through people
would teach it to other people and the
the was preserved through as well
through the
so this is hopefully that you understand
that
according to Timothy Kella there is an
academic research into the early
compiling of the Quran is um how can we
be sure that manuscripts were not burned
because they were versus bothered the
companions well there'd have to be in a
massive tacic collusion for that to
happen to both of the companions there'd
be a massive tacic collusion and
remember at this time there were
companions that were actually in
conflict of interest with one another
the companions were not monies and this
shows you has as well and is avoids uh
stopped some of the people from saying
these things because on one plane some
Sahabah had different interest than
other Sahabah are big group. So
sometimes
which is it stops people from saying
that they colluded on everything.
Uh nearly finished.
Oh is it time? Is it
in five minutes?
Oh 20 minutes ago. Oh subhah. Okay. I'll
answer three more questions. Regarding
the different mahibs, we are supposed to
respect all and follow the Quran. So now
yes, in line with Arabic language. Yes.
Where can we rewatch it?
Sapiens institute.org
J. Smith
Abdullah. Alhamdulillah for
and majority of if one actually
preserved can it be that each of theat
has chosen something else for one word
that there is a way it was forgotten is
this true or has or have all ways of
reading s always been preserved this is
the this is the debate there's some
words which were sorry some of which are
not preserved now are not being read but
the ones that we're reading are the ones
which represent. So yeah, this is uh but
the idea that there was no textual
criticism uh in the early I mean the
Christians are only doing textual
criticism now 2,000 years later. We've
been doing textual pism in the early
days. That's the difference between us
and them. They're so happy with their
textual criticism. They did it in the
wrong time. 2,000 years post date. We're
doing we did it 100 years after died.
One one year they started doing text
criticism after that's when you should
you should do text. Not 2,000 years
after the date. How many manuscripts so
far have been found that goes against?
So according to Muhammad Pan which I
found this in um
paper and I chased it up is 19 words or
19. Yeah with aith.
So that's hopefully you should calm
down. Subhan Allah. Yes I should calm
down. But sometimes you know get
passionate. Those who doubt have never
had a relationship with God. It was a
bit scary though. If people voice their
doubts when being Muslim, you should
react more calmly. Fair enough.
Someone's getting excited.
No, no, no. But to be honest with this
whole people voicing their doubts, I'm
sorry, but that some of how it was
dramatized
and I can tell you from experience like
when you see someone like that kind of
whimpering and embarrassed of the and
weak, the only way is to shout at them.
You know, if you saw your you
Um, there's all kinds of questions about
orientalist.
Um,
I'm trying to get a good question here.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Someone's asking about
the method that was required that each
person in the beginning in early days
needed two Sahaba in order for the for
the
each to be confirmed which is true.
No, the is not a specific way of reading
the whole Quran. It's a specific way of
reading one
ver one word.
Yeah. That's it's not the whole Quran.
It's one word.
So it's a difference in one word
according to it's difference of one in
one word rather than the whole Quran
is saying that the Quran has not changed
even a single word.
Yeah it's not changed. Why has it
changed? Why would you think that's the
wrong thing to say? How has it changed
is how's it corrupted? Nothing's been
added to it and nothing's been taken
from it from the what the authoral
intent.
We don't believe in corruption. Sorry to
say corruption the authoral intent Allah
intended this to be read in the prayers
of the Muslims and to and to be in this
is what's going to be with the Muslims
and that's it that's what is required
and that's we don't believe in the
corruption of that
some some are saying yes totally
understandable passion brothers some
people need to wake up and educate
themselves and others need to shut up
you this is more I believe you're right
and sister
I think this is just us on the
Anyways, with that guys, I think I I
need to pray a m prayer. Okay. Um
guys, I I you know what I do? I'll be
honest with you. I see if if you're
paying attention and if the attendees
are leaving, if I do, I start moving it
a bit, checking the tree a bit. Uh
because sometimes I feel like people are
not paying attention. But hopefully guys
go back on this webinar even if I'm
shouting or something you know or or be
speaking passionately and just read uh
through your notes and if you understand
it good no one can joke with you and no
one can play with you believe me because
anyone asks you now how how can you
explain this variance is have how can
you explain that variance have how can
you explain this have how can you
explain this manuscript have how can you
possibly have possibly basically it's
going to it's going to you can jab them
to death with with with with this and